so I'm gonna walk around the streets of
Hollywood and ask people they want to
eat a raw onion
[Music]
what do you guys think about onions I
love onions pretty good
I like onions lemon love use them all
the time
red organic quite sweet great they make
me cry I like them grilled
they got layers they're really good on
cheeseburgers I think millions are okay
sauteed I don't know my frog you like
onions raw actually it sometimes oh no
no not at all
yeah no no cry when you come no no
absolutely
do you want to eat Iranian for how much
nothing I can offer you is the onion for
free
nothing like that hi do you think an
extra onion idea I would consider it if
I was hungry enough I definitely would
do that would you consider it right now
no probably not right now would you eat
an entire raw onion no too much
no you sure it's too much are you gonna
do that for this video
no would you I wouldn't I probably I
might would you consider eating the
entire run in on camera yes I love you
sure why not okay here we go do you have
one of your I sure do I won't need it at
all hold the deal here's your sweet
onion how about it walks around with the
onion is back there
that's a decent bite don't breathe on me
yet do any more of this
it's delicious dude regretting your
decision I'm regretting grimaces you did
don't you take it kind of good
what's that onions doing to you that's
it that's it are you crying already so
beautiful that is all I can do I am very
glad that I stepped out of my comfort
zone today could you ever see yourself
get on that again no well yeah yeah I
don't know nobody nobody ever was a
better or worse than you expected it's
actually a little bit better because I
was expecting to maybe only take be able
to take one or two bites before I went
out but I am very proud of myself wait
half an onion today well folks we did it
we got people to take a bite of a raw
onion no real news that ridiculously
make real onions what are you doing